une requête sur la pénurie de
médicaments et les choix de l'industrie
pharmaceutique française poursuit
aujourd'hui ces travaux par l'audition
conjointe de plusieurs organismes
représentatifs des médecins
acteurs essentiels et pivot notre
système de santé c'est pas moi qui
dirige le contraire les médecins sont en
première ligne non seulement face au
fait aux pénuries de médicaments mais
également face au patients concernés
c'est pourquoi il nous a semblé
indispensable de vous entendre
aujourd'hui sur ce sujet précis parce
qu'elle vous contraignent adapter vos
prescriptions et vos stratégies
thérapeutiques voire l'organisation
coordonnée des soins les difficultés
d'approvisionnement médicament affectent
largement votre exercice elles ont aussi
des effets importants sur la prise en
charge des patients et leurs pronostic
que la commission d'enquête souhaite
mesurer nous avons posé cette question à
la CNAM le coût finalement
les effets secondaires de la pénurie et
c'est certainement un des éléments qui
manquent encore dans le pays les
informations nous pourrions avoir c'est
pourquoi il nous est particulièrement
précieux de bénéficier aujourd'hui de
votre expérience et de votre analyse non
pas seulement sur les causes de des
pénuries constatées parce que clairement
au niveau du diagnostic on commence à
avoir quelque chose d'un petit peu étayé
mais surtout sur leur conséquences dans
le suivi la prise en charge des patients
c'est-à-dire de façon pratiquante
comment ça se déroule la pénurie de
médicaments sur sur le terrain donc sans
présent autour de la table le professeur
Jean-Paul timon et le docteur Yves
juillet membre de l'Académie de médecine
le docteur claire ciré président de la
section santé publique de l'ordre
national des médecins le docteur Patrick
l'église déléguée générale de
l'intersydicat des praticiens
hospitaliers et il me manque
voilà et madame Lucie Hugues qui
représente qui accompagne juriste
de l'ordre national des médecins je
précise que MG France premier syndicat
représentatif des médecins généralistes
s'est déclaré
n'a pas pu répondre à notre
sollicitation
et nous les donc reconvoquerons lors
d'une nouvelle table ronde je vous
souhaite nous souhaiterions madame
messieurs que vous puissiez présenter
très concrètement dans un bref très bref
j'insiste
propos introductif la manière sinon je
raccourcirai le propos de mon propre
chef dans un bref propos introductif la
manière dont les pénuries médicaments
affectent la prise en charge des
patients et les conditions de travail
des médecins je vous serai tout à tour
la parole pour une durée de 5 minutes et
non pas 10 que je vous demanderai de ne
pas dépasser puisque vous êtes nombreux
à avoir répondu à notre invitation ce
dont nous nous félicitons puis madame
Laurence Cohen donc rapporteur de notre
commission d'enquête vous posera une
première série de questions à laquelle
je vous demanderai de de répondre je
précise que cette audition est diffusée
en direct sur le site internet du Sénat
et qu'elle fera l'objet d'un compte
rendu publié avant de vous donner la
parole je vous rappelle qu'un
excusez-moi faut témoignages devant
notre commission d'enquête et passive
des peines prévues aux articles 4 34-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal je vous
invite chacun votre tour à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant je le jure professeur Jean-Paul
Timman
docteur claire ciré et Docteur Patrick
l'église
je vous remercie et donc maintenant vous
donner successivement la parole pour
quelques minutes par organise ou
institution
et vous voudrez bien le cas échéant
indiquez vos évanges duel lien d'intérêt
donc je vais commencer dans l'ordre
d'appel le professeur immense
j'ai 8 minutes de parole mais si vous
voulez on pourra raccourcer
je ne savais pas les 5 bon le manque de
médicaments dans les pharmacies
hospitalières et de ville n'est pas
nouveau de 2010 des rapports signalaient
des ruptures d'approvisionnement attirer
l'attention des pouvoirs publics sur les
temps les dangers auxquels les malades
étaient exposées aggravation de la
maladie perte de chances de guérison
c'est aussi pour les praticiens à
l'hôpital comment ville une diminution
préoccupante de leur possibilité de
traitement d'autant plus qu'il n'existe
pas toujours des produits de
substitution disponibles
je voudrais ajouter ce que le Sénat a
déjà relevé le gaspillage du temps
médical qui en résulte alors depuis
malgré des interventions importantes
j'insiste des pouvoirs publics loi de
modernisation du système de santé
feuille de route ministérielle loi de
financement de sécurité sociale décret
relatifs au stock de sécurité la pénurie
n'a fait que s'aggraver le nombre de
signalements entre 2000 et 3000 par an
cette année certainement supérieur à
cette pénurie n'est pas seulement
française elle frappe tous les pays de
l'Union Européenne le Parlement européen
l'a identifié comme un problème majeur
de santé publique bon c'est-à-dire que
le problème est à la fois difficile et
complexe il s'explique au moins en
partie par une conjonction de différents
facteurs d'intérêts opposés médicaux
économique industrielle je me suis
limité au problème médicaux alors la
première question
est-ce que je peux avoir des
diapositives
voilà merci la première question c'est
d'identifier les médicaments qui
manquent alors quelques-uns sont listés
sur ce tableau vous les avez tous
entendu parler mais ils sont dans la
grande presse
d'une part des principes actifs soit la
molécule de base qui sert à fabriquer le
médicament alors vous les voyez ici par
acétamol xylocaine c'est-à-dire des
produits d'utilisation courante un
antibiotique l'amoxicilline un
anticancéreux le 5 fleureux et racines
sachant qu'il a aussi d'autres
indications est-ce qu'il me paraît
encore beaucoup plus important toute la
classe des glucocorticoïdes un seul
fabricant pour le monde entier donc
d'une part les principes actifs
deuxièmement les formes pharmaceutiques
c'est-à-dire le médicament proprement
dit
et là ce sont en grande partie les
préparations injectables utilisées
principalement à l'hôpital évidemment
dans les services d'urgence
c'est pénurie donc hospitalière 60% des
ruptures de raisonnement sont des
médicaments injectables
alors c'est clair que c'est difficile de
fabriquer des
solutions injectables techniquement
c'est difficile mais ce que je voudrais
dire c'est qu'il y a un savoir-faire en
France n'ont pas utilisé
et puis maintenant les médicaments
ciblés alors vers une population
particulière alors c'est ce sont les
médicaments pédiatriques le marché est
trop petit on dit que les Français ne
font plus d'enfants et puis aussi
gériatrique parce que les posologies de
a sont différentes de celles de l'adulte
jeune
ce que je voudrais signaler c'est que
toutes les classes forment écologiques
sont impactées par la pénurie et le Dieu
soit un arrêt de publication soit de
fabrication pardon soit un arrêt de
distribution la diapositive suivante
s'il vous plaît
positif suivant
pardon c'est celle d'avant
alors quels sont quels sont les causes
de la pénurie ben vous les connaissez je
vais les
répéter mais rapidement bon ces
médicaments sont des médicaments matures
ils sont relativement vieux entre
guillemets ça veut dire qu'ils ne sont
plus couverts par un brevet donc ils
sont copiables pratiquement on appelle
ça génial et ils sont généralement très
largement
copié en générique
leurs prix sont bas sauf à les fabriquer
à grande échelle ils ne sont pas
opérantables on comprend qu'il n'existe
qu'un petit nombre de fabricants parfois
un seul pour le monde entier il y a deux
chiffres qui sont intéressants 70% des
médicaments utilisés dans l'Union
européenne sont des génériques et ça
représente que simplement 30% du budget
global 70% 30%
. bon la fabrication est très
réglementée il est engadré avec de
nombreux sous-traitants chaîne de
fabrication complexes ce qui me paraît
important de vous dire c'est que leur
fabrication se fait à flux tendu c'est à
dire qu'il y a peu de stocks le
fabricant a donc tendance à privilégier
les acheteurs au prix les plus élevés
les prix sont fonctions du prix de vente
finale la France avait pris les plus bas
du marché c'est un handicap qui aggrave
notre pénurie nationale
diapositif suivante s'il vous plaît
alors ça très très rapide rapidement
pour vous montrer simplement les les
difficultés de la fabrication d'un
médicament à chacune de ces étapes du
principe actif jusqu'au médicament
principe c'est générique et il y a des
sous-traitants il y a donc des
sous-traitants ce qui fait que
l'ensemble est extrêmement fragile et on
peut voir que dès qu'un maillon de cède
et par la chaîne s'arrête donc
pratiquement la conclusion est-ce que
l'on peut
rapatrier toutes ces étapes
en France ou en Europe dans l'Union
européenne je pense que on ne peut pas
facilement le faire et qu'il faut
partager les rôles et poser la question
Quels sont les étapes que l'on peut
relocaliser dans l'Union européenne
diapositive suivante
quand on parle de pénurie on parle aussi
de stock de sécurité ça ça paraît
absolument l'évidence alors ce que je
veux dire c'est que en termes de stock
de sécurité l'administration était très
active elle a établi les médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur tout le
monde a entendu parler et mitaine des
règles de signalement de tension
d'approvisionnement de volume de stock
et de médicaments de substitution
lorsqu'ils existent mais
ces décisions françaises sortent à la
législation générale européenne de libre
circulation des biens à l'intérieur de
l'Union d'où des procès la justice
européenne c'est toujours prononcée en
interdisant les restrictions
quantitatives à l'exportation ce qui
fait que là il y a une divergence
d'appréciation entre la France d'une
part et l'Union européenne et je crois
que ça souligne l'intérêt de la mise en
place d'une politique européenne claire
de santé et de ressources thérapeutiques
agenciste beaucoup avec le problème donc
de des décisions de l'Union européenne
je voudrais maintenant vous signaler un
autre problème qui est un problème à mon
avis surtout national ce que j'appelle
le double problème français de l'accès
aux médicaments bon l'idée générale
c'est de relever les prix trop bas des
génériques plusieurs états alors levés
pour maintenir leur production mais
à l'opposé nous avons des médicaments
nouveaux des médicaments d'innovation
type anticorps monoclonaux ils sont
également disponibles eux ils ne sont
pas en pénurie mais ils sont très chers
la médecine en a besoin
question que peut-on payer et vous voyez
pour moi c'est une autre forme de
pénurie qui se profile et là encore un
arbitrage nécessaire dans une enveloppe
budgétaire je vous apprends rien qui
n'est pas extensible
merci des sources et des besoins
principes actifs alors là je parle de
principe actif non pas de médicaments la
France produit environ 6% de ses
principes actifs l'Europe hors France 9%
. c'est à dire qu'il y a 85 % des
principes actifs qui nous échappent que
nous sommes obligés d'emporter et
pratiquement c'est presque totalement de
la Chine et de l'Inde bon pour moi c'est
une situation qui est complètement
inacceptable c'est une revue c'est une
dépendance absolument insupportable pour
un pays comme le nôtre surtout que une
rupture d'approximité
d'approvisionnement est tout à fait
possible il y en a deux exemples le
premier c'est celui de l'Ukraine et bien
la guerre de l'Ukraine a diminué la
fabrication différents médicaments bon
on parle aujourd'hui malheureusement
d'une perspective de conflit entre la
Chine et l'Inde qu'est-ce qui restera
pour nos importations c'est pas sûr
sachant que c'est la Chine qui fournit
beaucoup de principes actifs à l'Inde
donc là encore je crois que il y a une
solution enfin il y a des solutions mais
ce qu'il faut c'est établir une liste
nationale des médicaments et
indispensables à partir des lycées
existantes alors bien sûr le MITM mais
aussi les médicaments critiques il faut
croiser avec celle des pénuries et
étudier au cas par cas les possibilités
de fourniture et de substitution
la diapositive suivante
alors quelques pistes pour assurer la
pérennité de nos approvisionnements
recolise relocalisation totale ou
partielle des fabrication est-ce qu'il
faut relocaliser le principe actif ou le
produit fini je pense que dans certains
cas cette pratique active dans d'autres
selles produits physiques il faut aussi
faire l'inventaire du tissu industriel
voire recenser les usines chimiques les
façonniers des gens qu'on pourrait faire
travailler sur notre sol deuxième chose
partage des relocalisations à
indispensables entre pays membres de
lieu en fonction de leur capacités
intellectuelles je suis pas naïf
jusqu'où la solidarité marchera-t-elle
entre les différents membres de l'Union
européenne c'est quand même une question
posée et puis ensuite
identifie identification d'autres
sources externes pérennes pour
diversifier nos sites
d'approvisionnement je conclus
pour moi la situation est grave et elle
implique d'agir vite
bon elle implique d'agir vite ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on ne peut pas
faire confiance à l'Europe parce que les
décisions sont beaucoup trop lentes ce
qu'on réussit pas à faire avec une seule
nation on va pas le faire plus
rapidement avec 27 je pense que c'est du
bon sens alors seuls des solutions
nationales pourront permettre un terme
pour en mettre un terme à la période de
pénurie que nous connaissons elle passe
par relèvement des prix les plus bas et
par une étude très sélective des besoins
nationaux orientés vraisemblablement
vers les principes actifs d'où la
nécessité d'adresser la liste tentez
ensuite de susciter voire de proposer
des solutions européennes aux problèmes
par exemple on pourrait partager la
réalisation des stocks de sécurité
suffisant pour toute l'Union européenne
visant à terme
le but c'est l'indépendance européenne
sanitaire enfin il faudrait que l'Union
européenne indique clairement la
politique qu'elle entend mener en
publiant sa loi sur les médicaments à
usage humain qui est dans la publication
et sans cesse reporter à l'heure
actuelle donc on attend la décision
européenne voilà le président ce que je
voulais vous dire
vous ne vous n'êtes pas sans ignorer la
dernière pénurie en date qui ait lieu
cet hiver et qui pourraient fait de
majorer les difficultés d'accès aux
soins de l'ensemble des patients qui
subissant déjà de plein fouet la pénurie
d'offre de soins se sont vu refuser la
délivrance voir la prescription de
certains médicaments au motif d'une
rupture de stock prévu sur plusieurs
mois dans le même temps évidemment
l'exercice de l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé dont les
médecins a été rendu très compliqué en
raison de la pénurie simultanée
d'antibiotiques majeur de cortisone
Perros et inhalée on peut paracétamol
alors qu'il devait faire face à trois
épidémies bronchiolite grippe covid
en fait là pour nous la problématique
principale c'est la méconnaissance peu
de monde en dehors des pharmaciens c'est
qu'on parle de rupture
d'approvisionnement de médicaments
lorsqu'une pharmacie est dans
l'incapacité de dispenser un médicament
à un patient dans un délai de 72 heures
peu de monde sait que pour connaître les
ruptures de stock connues sur le marché
le site de la NSM recense les listes des
produits concernés par les pénuries ou
les tensions d'approvisionnement et que
si le traitement n'est pas disponible en
officine le premier réflexe du
pharmacien devra être de proposer une
solution de remplacement avec par
exemple un générique pour se faire le
cnome ne s'est pas oublié il y a encore
j'ai depuis 2018 plusieurs actions un
premier partenariat avec la NSM afin de
travailler ensemble afin de pouvoir
donner les meilleures informations au
médecin dès que possible le cnome a créé
ainsi une rubrique vigilance éveil
sanitaire sur son site qui permet de
diffuser cette information mais aussi en
septembre 2019 a été mis en place par la
DGS un COPIL qui a fait 7 groupes de
travail et parmi ces 7 groupes de
travail nous avons avons travaillé sur
la transparence des qualités de
l'information qui a été à l'origine de
la de la rédaction du décret numéro 2021
349 que vous connaissez qui instaure
l'obligation pour les entreprises
pharmaceutiques de constituer un stock
de sécurité pour tous les médicaments
destinés au marché national et qui a été
publié le 30 mars 2029 pour une autre en
vigueur le 1er septembre 2021
par ailleurs en 2021 le cnome a
contribué à la rédaction de la
proposition de prise de position de
l'association médicalement mondiale en
soutien aux efforts visant assurer la
disponibilité la qualité et la sécurité
des médicaments dans le monde pour
rappel cette organisation internationale
de médecin fondée en 47 à l'épo pour
objectif d'assurer l'indépendance des
médecins et les plus hautes normes
possibles en matière d'éthique et de
soins c'est une confédération
d'associations professionnelles libres
financée par ses membres qui sont au
nombre de 116 nous avons fait 14
recommandations dont je vais vous donner
les principales
créer un organisme national chargé de
rassembler de faire connaître les
informations relatives à la demande et
l'offre de médicaments sur leur
juridiction établir des normes et des
mécanismes qui garantissent la
continuité de l'approvisionnement en
médicaments et ainsi évitent les
pénuries améliorer bien sûr la
surveillance de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement de ces médicaments
élaborer des stratégies d'atténuation
pour lutter contre la dépendance des
États à l'égard de la fabrication
étrangère de médicaments inciter les
autorités sanitaires nationales à
s'approvisionner en médicaments
essentiels afin de minimiser le risque
de pénurie et aussi permettre aux États
membres de l'AM d'acquérir grâce à des
contrats communs d'approvisionnement des
produits de santé vaccins en nombre
suffisants lors de pandémie et ainsi de
peser plus lourd dans les négociations
avec les laboratoires éviter aussi la
logique du premier arrivé premier servi
notamment situation de pandémie
engendrant une compétition
contre-productive allant à l'encontre de
la protection de la santé publique
nous avons continué en février 2022 en
participant avec NSM à plusieurs
réunions et cette pénurie de Me cet
hiver dont nous a parlé a été à
l'origine de 9 réunions communes afin de
pouvoir informer au plus près de la
situation l'ensemble des médecins du
territoire en effet l'ordre des médecins
communiquent par plusieurs relais son
site internet évidemment c'est baume
s'amuser sur linking et puis des brefs
santé publique nous faisons
régulièrement diriger à l'ensemble des
conseils départementaux mais malgré cela
l'ordre marque les informations n'est
toujours pas assez réactive et doit se
compléter en effet car si les
pharmaciens sont légitimement au fait de
ces informations les médecins restent
encore beaucoup trop concrètement
avertis par leur patient se pose alors
le problème des moyens alloués à
l'information afin qu'elle soit
accessible et complète alors que le
quotidien des médecins surmenait laisse
peu de place au simple au simple temps
médical
pour ce faire et je vais conclure le
cnome propose que ces informations de
tension d'approvisionnement et de
rupture de stock des médicaments ou
encore d'un éventuel plan blanc à mettre
en place soit disponible en temps réel
sur les logiciels d'aide à la
prescription des médecins sous forme
pourquoi pas d'une alerte ou bien via
une application smartphone
téléchargeable pour l'ensemble des
médecins mais aussi elle souhaiterait
que la population soit informée que les
pouvoirs publics accentuent leur
campagne d'information et de
sensibilisant à celle-ci quant à la
bonne utilisation des médicaments on
rappelle toujours les antibiotiques
c'est pas automatique ça a été tellement
important il s'agit d'éviter
l'automédication et de responsabiliser
la population je vous remercie
merci beaucoup docteur l'église s'il
vous plaît
un Président
je vous remercie de me donner la parole
j'ai simplement déjà vous présenter
quand même l'INPH qui est quand même qui
est un inter syndicat de praticien
hospitalier et qui regroupe une
quinzaine de syndicats parmi eux les
infectionologues les internistes les
chirurgiens pédiatres les il y a on a un
syndicat généraliste de
d'hospitalo-universitaires aussi enfin
bon des pharmaciens des sages-femmes et
aussi les dentistes les odontologistes
et pour votre information je dans le
civil je suis pharmacien hospitalier
voilà donc je sais que vous avez déjà
audité les pharmaciens donc je vais
essayer de pas répéter ce qu'ils ont dit
la seule chose c'est que avant juste les
remercier les mes collègues médecins
d'avoir
évité d'utiliser le terme molécule que
mes confrères en pharmacie m'ont utilisé
tout au long de cette audition et je
vous remercie beaucoup parce que et
parce que les frais termes c'est
médicament principe actifs excipient
mais la molécule je sais pas ce que
c'est voilà alors voilà après ce
préambule donc
il fallait il faut
les conséquences pour les patients c'est
ça que vous vouliez savoir mais en fait
comment ça se passe
comment ça se passe ben en fait il y a
en France il y a des pharmaciens qui
passent leur temps et qui ont des
obligations de résultats en terme de de
dispensation des médicaments et quand
ils ont des ordonnances ils sont ils ont
l'obligation de délivrer bien sûr après
une analyse pharmaceutique faut pas donc
ils ont une obligation de fournir des
médicaments et donc nous on passe notre
temps à à gérer les ruptures donc ça
c'est ça c'est important et ce qui fait
que par exemple dans les dans les
hôpitaux on a une quasiment une
obligation d'avoir un stock tampon ce
qui n'existe pas en ville ou en dans la
chaîne dans la chaîne officinale
et dégrossistes répartiteurs on est
plutôt dans du flux tendu comme comme on
l'expliquait mais dans les hôpitaux on a
un minima un mois de stock dans dans nos
pays
et donc ça nous permet de tamponner les
les différentes ruptures mais bien sûr
elles arrivent quand même jusque il
arrive un moment où elles arrivent
jusqu'à nous à ce moment-là qu'est-ce
qu'on
arrive soit à des modifications
traitement pour les pour les patients
les par exemple la plupart des
médicaments
de cardiologie par exemple les
anti-pertenseurs sont quasiment tous
interchangeables puisque dans une même
classe thérapeutique
on peut remplacer un certain par un
autre serpent on peut remplacer un IEC
par un autre IEC on peut remplacer un
émetteur classique par un autre émetteur
classique ça c'est et ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on fait communément depuis des
années dans les dans les hôpitaux
puisque on fait des appels d'offres on
fait des mises en concurrence et on
établit un livret thérapeutique et donc
quand un patient arrive dans un hôpital
et
qui est un médicament qui n'est pas qui
qui n'est pas au livret thérapeutique et
que on peut proposer aux médecins un
équivalent un équivalent pas forcément
un générique un équivalent il y a une
discussion médico-formatique qui
s'installe et on change le traitement et
ça pose ça pose aucun problème donc ça
c'est ça peut être ça peut être des
pistes de de solution parce que
il y a des pénuries mais il y a quand
même plus de 6000 je sais plus combien
il y a plus de 6000 spécialités sur le
marché français c'est-à-dire que moi
dans mon établissement je suis dans un
centre de gériatrie bon je n'utilise pas
énormément de médicaments mais on
utilise 800 800 médicaments maximum donc
voilà et un médecin dans sa dans sa vie
de dans sa vie de médecin en tout cas
généraliste il utilise il prescrit entre
200 et 300 médicaments dans sa carrière
il va pas voilà donc
il faut voir que on a quand même des
possibilités de
substitution mais mais ça et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on a qui a été évoqué
dans les autres auditions et c'est vrai
que avoir
quelque chose de bien établi et de et de
valider de façon académique par les
sociétés savantes de possibilités de
d'interchangeabilité de certains
médicaments ce serait ce serait ce
serait des pistes de
de réflexion donc les patients
moi quand je pose la question à mes j'ai
posé la question à mes médecins en fait
ils sont dans mon établissement ils sont
pas aperçus ils se sont aperçus de du
travail que l'on a fourni pour pour leur
fournir leurs médicaments mais ils ont
eu des alertes et on les a alertés
plusieurs fois et voilà
par nous oui oui par nous pardon oui oui
on a des on a et on a des ruptures tous
les quasiment toutes les toutes les
semaines et tous les jours et les
médicaments et encore les médicaments
c'est rien il y a les dispositifs
médicaux ils ont été mais on a on gère
par an 200 quasiment 200 ruptures en
termes de dispositif médicaux
donc c'est c'est énorme
moi je voulais revenir alors en fait en
termes
quand les ruptures concernent des
antibiotiques ça nous permet ça nous
oblige à faire des entorses au bon usage
des antibiotiques parce qu'on est obligé
par exemple de remplacer une un
antibiotique par un autre qui est pas
forcément recommandé dans la en première
ligne et qui élargit peut-être parfois
le spectre et donc qui est qui fait qui
nous fait faire des entorses au bon
usage donc ça c'est ça ça fait partie
des choses et puis bon bah les patients
ce qui ce qui pose le plus le plus de
problèmes c'est pour les patients qui
sont qui ont des pathologies chroniques
quand on leur change leur médicament
vous voyez ce qui s'est passé pour
l'allévo-thyroxine j'ai pas besoin de
vous expliquer la chose ça a posé
énormément de problèmes même si sur un
plan purement purement scientifique il y
avait pas de
et en termes d'équivalence il y avait
pas de il y avait pas de sujet
donc même en plus pour la levothyroxine
c'était c'était un médicament on a qu'on
a obligé de d'améliorer la qualité de
médicaments c'est
au laboratoire et ce qui a ce qui a fait
un tollé un tolé général mais moi je le
vois aussi quand on passe d'ingénierie à
un autre il y a il peut y avoir des
allergies qui se qui se développent et
voilà donc c'est une chose
moi je chaussais aussi
moi j'ai une question que j'avais ce que
je me pose c'est-à-dire qu'on a vu tous
les tableaux de pénurie sur
l'amoxicilline elle a elle part à cet
amole et on s'aperçoit qu'il y a trois
pays qui ont jamais eu de pénurie sur
ceux qui ont jamais eu qui ont pas eu de
tension sur ces sur ces produits là
la Norvège la Slovénie elle Danemark
alors moi j'aimerais bien savoir
pourquoi
j'ai pas analysé la chose et dans ce
dans ce contexte de tension on on a vu
que les que certains pays ont augmenté
leur prix le médicament c'est à dire
qu'on s'est retrouvé un peu dans la dans
la même crise que qu'avec les masques
pour la pour la covid c'est-à-dire que
ben
on augmente nos offres de prix pour pour
avoir plus pour pour
être prioritaire sur les sur les
livraisons donc
nous Sauveur de ma part je crois que le
Portugal avait rehaussé ses prix et je
crois que l'Allemagne aussi a fait la
même chose et hop comme par hasard ils
ont
il y a pas eu il y a eu beaucoup moins
de tension que qu'en France voilà donc
ça c'est ça c'est quelque chose qui est
important et la proposition
l'Académie de médecine de dire que il
faudrait qu'il y ait un prix régulé et
européens ça vraiment c'est s'il y a
vraiment une chose qu'il faudrait faire
c'est vraiment ça quoi c'est c'est
vraiment
la c'est vraiment la ce serait vraiment
la première chose parce que ça
permettrait déjà d'éviter cette
concurrence en état
sur ces sur les médicaments bon il y a
je voulais juste aussi
insister sur le sujet des des appels
d'offres nationaux franchement ça c'est
c'est le
moi ça fait ça fait plus de 10 ans que
je me bats contre ça ça a été instauré à
l'époque je crois que la directrice de
l'offre de soins c'était Annie poder et
donc on nous a mis dans les pattes
uniasha et puis et tout ça au niveau des
hôpitaux et ça a contribué sa conduite
tribu fortement alors pas forcément sur
la médicament mais principalement sur
les dispositifs médicaux vraiment à
ça ça contribue d'abord a tué la
concurrence à sécher le marché et à
diminuer le nombre de d'acteurs sur le
sur les territoires français donc là il
serait bien temps de de
mettre en place ce qui avait été ce qui
avait été recommandé d'ailleurs par la
DGS
il y a récemment c'est de mettre en
place des appels d'offres régionaux
et afin de de morceler le enfin de de
d'arrêter cette massification des appels
d'offres
l'autre
point que je voulais alors oui aussi
c'est bon les détermination des prix en
France pose problème
on est
et
on est sur une donc sur une
établissement des prix en fonction de du
service du service médical rendu
qui est assez limite
et mais pas seulement sur le service
médical rendu les les laboratoires
proposent des
propose des négocier avec les États en
fonction de leur solvabilité Marion je
prends l'exemple des médicaments de
à leur époque contre l'hépatite C les
prix proposés pour en Inde des bien
inférieurs à les prix proposés en France
l'un des temps moins solvables que la
France voilà donc il y a pas que une
question de SMR et donc je pense qu'il
faut maintenant il faut quand même voir
aussi cet aspect là alors bon pas avoir
des prix mondiaux parce que ça me semble
impossible mais au moins européen ça ça
c'est clair et
et arrêter de d'assécher le le
marché des génériquesurs parce que à
force de baisser les prix sur les
génériques bon on va finir par les faire
fermer les uns après les autres et je
pense que ça
je pense que ça a déjà commencé
voilà juste je peins rajouter plus juste
une petite chose une petite
un petit point à rajouter c'est sur la
sur les préparations hospitalières
spéciales et je pense que c'est une
bonne chose que ça a été introduit dans
le palais FSS de dans la LFS de 2022 et
je pense qu'il faut vraiment le soutenir
et
actuellement il y a des textes européens
qui tentent à limiter les préparations
hospitalières pour des pour des durées
de 7 jours et je pense qu'il est
important que la France monte au créneau
là-dessus parce que ça va tuer la
possibilité de faire des préparations
hospitalières à l'hôpital en France
voilà c'est c'est un point d'alerte et
je et ça c'est quelque chose qui alors à
l'hôpital mais
la c'est ce qui nous a permis en tout
cas à l'officine de pouvoir pallier
la pénurie de
d'amoxicilline puisqu'ils ont pu faire
des préparations magistrales
à grande échelle voilà c'est tout ce que
je voulais rajouter
merci beaucoup je vais passer la parole
à Laurence Cohen pour une première salve
de questions et après je passerai la
parole à
nos collègues qui souhaiteront vous
interroger également
oui merci
Monsieur et Madame pour vos propos
introductifs qui ont bien balayé la
problématique même si c'est toujours sur
un temps contraint et donc il faut
synthétiser les propos mais après il y a
le jeu des questions et des et des
réponses donc il a été il a été dit par
plusieurs d'entre vous que il y avait un
problème de prix notamment des
génériques et qu'à force de de baisser
les prix des génériques et bien on avait
le résultat que l'on connaît dans
plusieurs de nos de nos auditions il a
été fait un comparatif avec d'autres
pays européens montrant que d'autres
pays européens avaient des prix plus
élevés mais que ça n'avait rien changé
donc c'est c'est vrai que les pénuries
sont multifactorielles que il s'agit pas
pour moi de simplifier ni pour vous
d'ailleurs de simplifier le propos mais
j'aimerais vous entendre sur sur le
sujet parce que il semblerait que ça ne
soit pas une des solutions
obligatoiresment prioritaires ça c'est
ma ma première ma première question vous
avez été aussi plusieurs à signifier le
l'information insuffisante ou le manque
d'information en tout cas en amont
anticipé je dirais sur
les ruptures éventuelles les tensions de
d'un certain nombre de médicaments
pourtant normalement l'Agence nationale
de sécurité du médicament
est chargé de de vous alerter donc
est-ce que vous pouvez là encore donner
un certain nombre d'éléments pour à la
fois montrer les manques et en même
temps faire des propositions pour que
pour les modifier parce que notre
commission d'enquête c'est effectivement
à la fois faire un état des lieux mais
c'est surtout faire un certain nombre de
recommandations pour se sortir de cette
de cette aussi situation vous avez
évoqué mais vous êtes passé assez
rapidement sur les conséquences
des conséquences sanitaires de ces de
ces pénuries plusieurs d'entre vous ont
parlé de possibilités de substitution
mais avec un certain nombre
d'inconvénients mais dans nos auditions
jusqu'à présent c'est quand même une
partie qui est très peu documentée nous
n'avons pas réussi à avoir des éléments
très précis je pense notamment pour les
personnes qui sont atteintes de cancer
on nous a quand même dit qu'il y avait
une perte de chance qui était évidente
sur un nombre d'années de vie non
négligeable donc est-ce que vous avez
plus d'éléments sur sur cette question
parce que ça nous paraît important
sur les médicaments en tension il y a
plusieurs listes qui sont
vous allez dire concurrente on nous
parle beaucoup d'hélice des listes des
listes mais tout le monde fait
spécialiste et au bout du bout il nous
semble pas qu'il y ait une coordination
voire un chemin pour croiser ses listes
et il nous semble aussi que
les mouvements d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeurs finalement pour que ça soit
efficace
aurait peut-être besoin d'être réduit
parce que une liste trop longue
finalement nuit à l'efficacité des
recommandations donc qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez et puis j'ai parlé de
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur mais là on voit que de plus en
plus plus on avance plus toutes les
classes de médicaments sont touchées et
tout dernièrement là j'ai été alerté
comme plusieurs de mes collègues et
vous-mêmes sur une pénurie ou une
tension des pilules abortives donc on
n'est pas là sur des médicaments je
pense l'intérêt thérapeutique majeur
mais ce sont des médicaments qui sont
extrêmement importants pour choisir
de continuer
à avoir à venir à bien la gestation ou
pas donc j'aimerais avoir votre votre
avis et
une question encore c'est sur le fait le
docteur claire Ciret a parlé de
nécessité de campagne d'information pour
pour que les patients ne fassent pas
d'auto médication etc etc mais on a vu
aussi qu'il y avait visiblement en
France un problème un peu de
surconsommation de médicaments qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez et moi il me semble
que les meilleurs campagnes
d'informations soient-elles il y a
besoin on parle là de prévention et on
parle d'éducation à à la santé et là
c'est plus à mon avis une prérogative du
gouvernement et du ministère de la Santé
donc qu'en pensez-vous
et enfin la dernière question excusez
moi j'en ai beaucoup ce concerne là
encore vous l'avez un petit peu abordé
les médicaments innovants on voit bien
là quand même que ces médicaments
innovants et c'est très bien ne sont pas
victimes de pénurie voire de tension
mais leur prix des filles j'allais dire
toute concurrence c'est à dire que y
compris ça peut poser et ça pose parfois
le prix la question du tri des patients
parce que tout le monde ne peut pas
bénéficier de de ce traitement donc là
encore qu'en pensez-vous et merci par
avance
docteur juillet
je vais essayer de reprendre un certain
nombre de choses vous allez poser
beaucoup de questions mais peut-être une
synthèse de ce qui a été dit
antérieurement en quelques mots donc il
est clair que globalement il y a une
tension sur l'ensemble des marchés sur
le plan mondial sur les médicaments
parce que la consommation augmente au
niveau mondial et la production
n'augmente pas la même mystère c'est la
première chose il y a deuxièmement un
problème spécifique français c'est qu'on
a plus de pénuries en France que dans
d'autres pays européens qui sont
comparables en particulier pays du nord
de l'Europe il y a pas de il y a pas de
pénurie et d'autre part il y a un
certain nombre de pays qui ont pris des
mesures ce qui a été évoqué des mesures
d'augmentation de prix au Portugal en
Espagne et au Danemark et en Norvège
donc il y a eu des sur la sur les
solutions à courtes il y a du court
terme et du monde et du et du long terme
le court terme c'est d'essayer de
pallier la difficulté qui se pose au
quotidien il y a un certain nombre de
produits très précis dont on sait que le
problème est quand même très proche du
problème du prix quand vous voyez qu'un
traitement anti-pertenseurs un
diurétique comme les yques est à 4 euros
10 pour 3 mois de traitement vous vous
dites que c'est quand même pas
grand-chose et donc il faudrait regarder
de près pour les produits qui sont en
rupture quelle est leur prix et voir
avec les pouvoirs publics ce qui se
passe il y a également alors là ça c'est
pour le court terme donc il faudrait
regarder sur les produits qui sont en
tension quel est leur prix et comment
éventuellement s'il y a des solutions
pour le moyen terme on parle de
relocalisation on parle de production en
France mais tout ceci s'inscrit dans des
années et des années il faut se faire
aucune illusion et même quand on parle
du paracétamol recueil relocalisé en
France ce sont les dernières étapes les
premières étapes elles sont toujours en
Chine donc ce que fait c'est quoi c'est
bien mais ce sont les deux dernières
étapes les deux premières étapes c'est
en Chine et il faut savoir que la
relocalisation en France ça veut dire un
certain nombre de conséquences ces
remèdes de l'industrie chimique
polluante éventuellement avec des des
spécificités il faut les accepter comme
tel troisième point dans le quotidien il
faut essayer quand même de valoriser si
on fait des relocalisations ce qui se
passe en France or actuellement mon
voisin a évoqué les appels d'offres mais
si vous avez un ou deux centimes d'euros
qui sont supérieurs bien que ça soit une
production en France on choisit ce qui
est moins cher donc il ne faut pas être
schizophrène dans la manière dont on
gère cela et donc considérer des appels
d'offres plus spécifiques et avec une
base nationale et non plus seulement
européenne il faut voir comment ça peut
se faire sur le plan légal mais c'est
une piste qu'il faut regarder de près
alors maintenant je voudrais je voudrais
répondre à la question concernant les
patients c'est un poids tout à fait
important parce que je pense qu'on n'a
pas assez répondu à vos à vos questions
sur ce sujet
le médecin il est pas directement en
première ligne au premier degré je veux
dire il fait sa prescription et le
patient il va où il va à la pharmacie et
à la pharmacie qu'est-ce qui se passe et
bien il y a pas le médicament donc le
pharmacien essaie de se débrouiller
d'abord tout seul donc il essaie de
faire de trouver des produits alors vous
savez que il y a des substitutions avec
des produits qui sont importés il y a
des autorisations d'importation
spécifique pour certains produits en
rupture la NSM donne des autorisations
de ce genre sauf que récemment exemple
le paracétamol sirop enfant est arrivé
de d'Allemagne avec des notices
seulement en allemand donc vous voyez la
tête des parents donc le pharmacien est
en première ligne il essaie de se
débrouiller quand il arrive pas à se
débrouiller il vient il se retourne vers
le médecin parce que lui il a pas le
droit de faire la substitution
thérapeutique là on parle de la ville on
parle pas de l'hôpital le pharmacien
hospitalier ont beaucoup plus de
possibilités et donc en ville il est
obligé de se retourner vers le médecin
donc ce qui est tout à fait fondamental
c'est le dialogue entre le pharmacien et
le médecin et la confiance qui est
établie qui est qui doit se maintenir se
développer entre le pharmacien et le
médecin sur les substitutions
thérapeutiques qui sont dans un certain
nombre de cas nécessaire alors
maintenant la question que vous avez
posée concernant la réalité de gens qui
sont sans traitement du tout je pense
que c'est quand même relativement
exceptionnel je pense que si c'était le
cas ça serait sorti dans la presse on en
aurait entendu parler on en a pas
réellement entendu parler donc il y a
peut-être quelques cas mais tout à fait
exceptionnel donc je pense que dans la
plupart des cas actuellement on arrive
par des substitutions thérapeutiques à à
des solutions mais la substitution
thérapeutique n'est pas une panacée on
dit qu'on est on a dit que on pouvait
échanger un certain temps par un autre
on peut en théorie mais en pratique pas
si évident que ça il faut que ça soit
suivi or si à l'hôpital on peut le faire
parce que les médecins sont là en
permanence ça n'est pas le cas en ville
et d'autre part il y a tout le problème
du patient lui-même il faut que le
patient il puisse comprendre ce qui se
passe et si il y a le moindre problème
qui puisse immédiatement avoir un
recours et ce recours il est difficile
et c'est là où il y a encore la
conjonction entre le pharmacien et le
médecin le pharmacien est d'accès
beaucoup plus facile que le médecin en
pratique et donc le pharmacien est amené
à répondre à un certain nombre de
questions quotidiennes parce que le
patient peut venir le voir sans
rendez-vous contrairement contrairement
aux médecins c'est beaucoup plus
difficile donc on voit on voit sur ce
sujet des patients la nécessité absolue
absolue d'une conjonction entre la
profession pharmaceutique et la
profession médicale avec une difficulté
qui a bien été expliquée par Madame
siret c'est que les médecins en général
sont beaucoup moins bien informés que
les pharmaciens les pharmaciens sont en
ligne directe sur ces sujets c'est leur
métier avec les pouvoirs publics avec la
NSM c'est beaucoup moins le cas pour les
médecins et donc il y a une difficulté
il faudrait que les médecins puissent
avoir une information plus régulière
voilà les quelques points que je voulais
aborder répondre à une partie seulement
de vos questions
merci beaucoup docteur Cyril oui je veux
bien rebondir parce que j'ai aussi fait
pas mal de remarques je vous remercie
parce que vous avez fait un bon tableau
de ce qui se passe et toutes les
questions que vous avez posées autant le
prix pour nous c'est quelque chose
d'obscur et donc on ne maîtrise pas du
tout déjà quand les génériques sont
arrivés on n'a pas tout à fait compris
en quoi ça nous arrangeait puisque les
passions ont été complètement
déboussolées que ça a modifié les
consultations et que pour un prix qui
parfois le principe était aussi peu cher
et donc les prix avaient été baissés on
n'a pas tout compris donc ça on a
l'impression quand même que ça nous
échappe et que parfois finalement c'est
pas le sujet et que on se demande si la
santé publique doit payer
pour pour ce prix là nous ce qui nous
intéresse beaucoup plus c'est le
conditionnement on se demande s'il
faudrait pas qu'on délivre au nombre de
comprimés utiles on se dispute sur des
boîtes à 28 comprimés des boîtes à 30
comprimés et on est toujours dans ces
histoires de boîte à rattraper qu'il
faut faire une nouvelle prescription et
parfois une nouvelle consultation on se
dispute aussi si vous en parler du
doliprane le doliprane sirop c'est une
pipette qui est extrêmement peu de kilos
donc en fait il vous faut un nombre de
flacons énorme parce que les enfants
aiment bien le sirop puisqu'il y a un
bon goût et donc à 12 ans parfois vous
avez encore du sirop et vous avez des
tout petits flacons ne comprend pas
qu'ils puissent pas y avoir d'autres
modes de conditionnement qu'un petit
Flaco avec 8 kg je crois que c'est 8 kg
à pipette enfin bref voilà c'est des
petites choses comme ça qui au quotidien
nous nous perturbe beaucoup vous avez
par exemple le doliprane en 300 mg en
sachet qui est pris en charge mais si
c'est le conditionnement sirop sous
forme extrêmement pratique pour les
mamans il est pas remboursé il ça aussi
ça nous pose des questions voilà donc on
est plutôt dans le pratique aux
pratiques sur l'information j'y reviens
c'est extrêmement dommageable que le
médecin ne soit pas préalablement averti
des pénuries oui bien sûr il y a le site
de la NSA mais encore une fois quand
est-ce qu'on le fait à quel moment on
doit y aller est-ce que c'est tous les
jours trois fois par jour c'est pas
possible concrètement on a déjà du mal à
tout gérer il faut être honnête il faut
qu'aujourd'hui on nous facite
l'information et si l'application
smartphone fait sourire nous on pense
que c'est le meilleur moyen de
communication puisque aujourd'hui vous
le savez communiquer vers les médecins
est devenu un sujet c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui ils en veulent plus les
journaux une les lisent pas la télé
coûte plus donc ils sont saturés donc il
faut une information directe efficace
qui donne les bons éléments et qu'est-ce
qu'on a besoin la durée j'ai les trois
éléments c'est important c'est la durée
de la pénurie il a raison la pénurie et
puis les substitutions possibles et donc
il faut qu'on soit pratique et efficace
et cette information je suis désolé il
est dommage que ce soit le pharmacien et
pire le patient qui nous avertisse parce
que ça serait beaucoup plus intelligent
qu'on prescrive tout de suite pour le
pharmacien la bon médicament pour que ça
lui évite de nous appeler alors que nos
standards sont surchargés et qu'il
arrive pas à nous joindre que donc il
démissionne il va donner quelque chose
il va renvoyer le patient à la
secrétaire pour dire aller voir votre
médecin parce qu'on peut faire on est
dans les cas pratiques d'impossibilité
de ce contacter c'est pas par manque de
volonté c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui tout
est saturé
les conséquences sanitaires de ces
pénuries elles sont dramatiques c'est un
problème majeur de santé publique pour
adhérer à son à son traitement un
patient doit être en confiance et
aujourd'hui il ne l'est plus et quand
vous avez Ludie bah oui vous avez
peut-être une infection virale mais vous
revenez me voir dans trois jours parce
que aujourd'hui je peux pas vous donner
une antibiotique il y en a pas il y a
des pénuries et puis on n'est pas très
sûr que ce soit pas viral vous pouvez
pas avoir un discours comme ça vous
pouvez pas avoir une proposition de la
NSM qui dit pour toute suspicion
d'angine donne avec de l'amoxicilline le
pharmacien demandera à son patient si
c'est bien une angine qui devait être
soignée et si le médecin n'a pas fait le
trod et ben il le fera et donnera pas la
mexicilline si il trop de négatif on
peut pas travailler comme ça c'est
remettre en question la capacité du
médecin à faire son diagnostic et ses
données des responsabilités pharmaceiens
qui à mon avis le dépasse mais cela
n'engage que mon moi médecin généraliste
voilà sur la liste trop longue oui il y
en a plein il y en a plein des
médicaments on sait plus quoi faire pour
proposer des tas de choses à des
patients alors que finalement peut-être
que deux ou trois médicaments dans une
vous suffirait mais l'ordre bien
évidemment ça ne lui appartient pas et
puis si la médecine est devenue une
consommation un service quelque chose
qu'on peut consommer comme on en a envie
c'est fort dommage et nous essayons
lutter contre cette image sur les
médicaments innovants j'aurais pas trop
de de retour à vous faire bien
évidemment je pense qu'ils sont
importants pour le reste cela nous
appartient pas voilà je pense que j'ai
encore d'autres choses à vous dire mais
sur l'antibiotique les pénuries on n'a
pas parlé d'antibio résistance c'est à
dire que quand vous switchez la
moxissime pour autre chose vous rentrez
dans l'anti-burésistance et toutes ces
problématiques autre de santé publique
qui sont dramatiques
merci beaucoup docteur l'église juste
une petite remarque pour l'angine il y a
pas que la moticilline on peut on peut
écrire des macrolides aussi mais bon on
est d'accord
alors ce sujet
oui
mais bon
juste pour les prix
quand un médicament est dans le prix est
fixé à 2 centimes d'euros le comprimé
vous imaginez bien que c'est pas le
c'est en dessous du prix de revient
industriel honnêtement
je reprends l'exemple de Monsieur Bessey
qu'il a donné avec la lévothyrox 25 or
les prix qu'il a annoncé c'est pas
vraiment ça mission on prend le livre de
25 c'est 2 centimes d'euros le comprimé
c'est pas possible donc c'est évident
que c'est en dessous du prix de revient
et ça évident que le l'industriel qui
vend des voitures racines 25 en France
ils perdent l'argent c'est évident c'est
voilà donc un moment faut payer le vrai
prix je sais que je
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre et je
pense que le jour où on paiera le vrai
prix sur ces médicaments là je pense que
les produits les
les médicaments innovants coûteront
moins cher c'est à dire que à un moment
il va y avoir un rééquilibrage mais là
c'est en fait c'est et ça tout ça c'est
l'effet alors je veux juste faire une
petite digression c'est un peu l'effet
pervers de la dame de l'enveloppe fermée
de l'âme c'est-à-dire que on on ferme
l'enveloppe donc on doit pas dépenser
plus que ça en médicament donc on tire
les prix au plus bas c'est pareil pour
les hôpitaux on on baisse les les tarifs
de la T2A alors là on a de la chance ils
ont été un peu maintenus mais pendant
des années ils ont baissé baissé ce qui
fait que les hôpitaux ont été de faits
en en déficit chronique structurelle et
donc voilà donc à un moment donné il va
falloir se poser la question de de
revoir le financement
de la santé en France quoi simplement
faut arrêter avec le et donc financé en
fonction des besoins et pas en fonction
d'une enveloppe voilà
je vais passer la parole
à mes collègues Corinne Imbert
merci madame la Présidente merci madame
messieurs pour pour vos interventions du
coup je suis très intéressant mais du
coup j'aurais plein de choses à dire des
remarques des questions alors je pense
que je pas monopoliser la parole ça
serait pas sympa pour mes collègues je
vais essayer de faire très court merci
d'avoir parlé de l'âme parce que c'est
quand même le coeur du sujet
en tout cas c'est
parce qu'on a une sécurité sociale parce
qu'il y a des objectifs de dépenses
d'assurance maladie peut-être qu'on en
est là aussi et vous l'avez évoqué en
moyenne aller un milliard d'économies
sur le médicament chaque année et
pendant depuis trois quatre ans un
milliard d'économies sur de l'hôpital et
pour parler que des derniers projets de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale donc effectivement
il demande mondiale qui qui augmente et
d'un autre côté nous sommes contraints
en France par notre système de
solidarité que représente la sécurité
sociale à essayer de contraindre les
prix et vous l'avez bien décrit alors du
coup je reviens à votre proposition
comment vous imaginez
qui puisse être possible d'avoir un prix
régulé européen tous les pays n'ont pas
un système qui était équivalent notre
tous les pays n'ont pas une sécurité
sociale
généreuse solidaire comme la nôtre
comment à un moment donné de votre point
de vue vous pouvez imaginer qu'on puisse
avoir un prix européen qui soit qui soit
régulée
est-ce que sur les appels d'offres alors
je partage complètement ce que vous avez
dit sur les conséquences néfastes des
appels d'offres nationales enfin des
appels d'oft on va mettre nationaux ce
sera mieux voilà merci excusez-moi
qui ont un système d'information qui le
déperuptures qui est qui est à mon avis
très intéressant en termes d'information
une remarque à titre personnel je
regrette une chose mais je ne sais pas
si les industriels seraient en mesure de
nous la donner c'est une date prévisible
de réapprovisionnement nous n'avons pas
alors nous avons la
cause de rupture consiste un problème
sur le fabrication sur la chaîne ça on
l'a la demande mondiale évidemment mais
nous n'avons jamais
quasiment jamais de prévisible de
réapprovisionnement est-ce qu'à votre
niveau vous avez connaissance de cela
est-ce que vous pensez qu'au niveau des
industriels c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait être envisagé tout en sachant
que si la demande mondiale continue et
que les prix sont plus intéressants pour
les labos il y aura des fabrications
médicaments et ils seront pas vendus sur
le territoire français
une une peut-être une
en fin de remarque parce que je vais je
vais arrêter juste une remarque sur le
déconse initialement des médicaments je
pense que c'est une fausse bonne idée ça
a été expérimenté
quand le pharmacien délivre un
traitement antibiotique pour 7 jours
pour 7 jours conformément la
prescription on adapte enfin en tout cas
si c'est six jours alors qu'on a des
boîtes de 14 comprimés à deux par jour
on va dire de terminer la boîte sauf que
si le patient est pour trois jours vous
aurez délivré vos 12 ou 14 comprimés
patient qui arrêtera au bout de trois
jours de traitement il arrêtera bout de
trois jours il en restera toujours vous
avez raison sur les antibiorésistances
évidemment
autre inconvénient et j'en viens sur le
l'intérêt des patients parce que c'est
quand même eux qui sont au cœur du
problème en tout cas qui porte les
conséquences de tout cela même quand on
fait une substitution
et pour des patients même j'allais dire
peut-être surtout chronique qui ont
l'habitude d'avoir la boîte avec écrit
en bleu et le filet jaune en bas où ce
que vous voulez même si vous donnez un
équivalent thérapeutique etc et que la
boîte change de couleur et qu'ils ont
encore deux trois comprimés chez eux
parce que c'est un traitement chronique
et bien là il faut beaucoup
d'informations beaucoup de pédagogie
pour qu'il y ait pas des doubles prises
pour qu'on ait pas des des risques de à
la fois d'y être génie et de de
surdosage parce que on aura pris le
médicament comprendre d'habitude et on
prend le nouveau qui a été délivré alors
que c'est le même voilà il y a tous et
là je pense qu'on les pharmaciens les
médecins sont
qu'on y met tous de la bonne volonté
pour informer à vous donner la bonne
information par an et là aux parents aux
patients pardon et les alertés sur les
risques de d'erreur de prise ou de
surprise à cause d'un changement de
conditionnement tous en sachant que le
traitement sera le même il va être bien
et bien délivré donc il y a tous ces
problèmes qui sont des effets des
conséquences des
substitutions
de médicaments je m'arrête là mais je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup
Corinne Alexandra
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues je voudrais tout d'abord vous
remercier pour vos propos liminaires
Mesdames et Messieurs Je voulais vous
interroger sur deux points plus précis
d'abord dans son étude sur la fracture
sanitaire en France qui a été publiée en
novembre 2022 l'UFC Que Choisir dresse
le constat accablant cependant connu
bien sûr du difficile accès aux soins de
nos concitoyens puisque 1,7 millions de
Français se trouvent dans un désert
médical les Français on le sait sont des
consommateurs assez importants de
médicaments puisque puis de 400 millions
de boîtes sont délivrées par an
probablement beaucoup les utilisent mal
ainsi j'aimerais avoir votre sentiment
sur l'existence d'un potentiel lien de
causalité entre désert médicaux et
mauvaise consommation de médicaments
autrement dit pensez-vous que la pénurie
de médecins dans certains territoires
est un impact réel sur la pénurie de
médicaments et puis je voulais enfin
évoquer avec vous un deuxième point avec
ou sans ordonnance plus de 40% des
Français consomment des médicaments au
quotidien alors on vient d'en parler les
pharmacies bien sûr constitue l'accès
premier aux médicaments cependant une
enquête réalisée par hugove en 2018 a
mis en lumière le recours à l'achat de
médicaments en ligne puisque plus de 15%
des Français auraient déjà acheté des
médicaments par ce biais et puis 20% des
Français qui n'ont pas encore effectué
d'achat pharmaceutique sur le web
envisagerait de le faire dans le futur
donc ma question est la suivante
avez-vous le sentiment qu'il existerait
aussi impossible lien de cause à effet
entre l'automédication dont font usage
les Français la pénurie de médicaments
je vous remercie
oui merci à tous moi je voudrais revenir
sur le problème du prix parce que ils
reviennent au fil des éditions très
régulièrement
vous avez insisté
vous l'avez évoqué sur le fait de
problèmes que pose effectivement la dame
qui augmente d'ailleurs moins vite que
que le coût de l'inflation et qui
entraînait certainement de dérives parce
qu'on n'est pas assez de moyens
la clause de sauvegarde était née du
fait de dire que c'était du
gagnant-gagnant ont diminué le prix des
médicaments qui étaient délivrés en
grande quantité etc donc des prix des
médicaments matures et à contrario cela
permettait de donner les prix
intéressants sur l'innovation or on voit
qu'il y a une dérive extrêmement
importante puisque effectivement les
prix des produits mature ou très matures
frises vous venez de le dire j'allais
dire presque le ridicule à 2 centimes le
comprimés mais on a par contre des prix
de médicaments innovants extrêmement
cher on parle de 1 million d'euros deux
millions d'euros récemment pour un
traitement enfin pour les thérapies
géniques et la personne ne parle de
réguler ce prix là et moi ça me choque
parce que je trouve que on entend on a
reçu l'industrie pharmaceutique on
entend les laboratoires toujours se
plaindre du prix trop bas des
médicaments il ne part jamais du prix
excessif
sujet médicament innovants et on n'avons
aucune transparence sur les modalités de
fixation des prix et en particulier de
ces médicaments innovants alors est-ce
que vous avez vous des propositions qui
nous permettraient d'améliorer ce
transparence d'abord que pensez-vous de
la nécessité d'une transparence sur ces
prix et puis comment peut-on réguler ces
prix pour qu'on ait plus se différencier
parce que effectivement entre quand on a
une thérapie génique à un million
d'euros on comprend bien que ça nous
fait nous est dit un jour alors c'était
pas sur ce sujet sur cette mission mais
c'était au cours d'une autre audition
qu'ils avaient donné la recherche en
chimie parce que la recherche en
thérapie génique était beaucoup plus
intéressante et rapporter beaucoup plus
et on le comprend il faut boire vendre
beaucoup de bois de paracétamol pour
arriver au prix d'une seule injection de
thérapie génique donc comment à votre
avis peut-on agir sur cette transparence
et comment peut-on j'allais dire
limiter aux juguler les appétits des
grandes bics d'armates qui n'ont plus
limite vous vous avez évoqué le fait de
la différence entre l'Inde et la France
c'est choquant
OK et donc moi je vais poser mes
quelques questions j'apprends je propose
un tour de réponse
[Musique]
parmi les recommandations que vous
préconisez tous il y a l'information
auprès de auprès du médecin et donc elle
solution vous proposez on a eu l'époque
des DGS urgents qui sont moins fréquents
là mais à une époque on en est enfin 4 5
par jour donc ce qui pourrait pas y
avoir un véhicule Haddock parce que pour
le coup c'est lu quand même par les par
les médecins un véhicule Haddock pour
informer des pénuries
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez du retour sur le
terrain des différences de répartition
territoriale des pénuries parce que
voilà d'un territoire à l'autre c'est
pas les mêmes pénuries parce que ça
dépend de la répartition en fait et des
fournisseurs et donc du coup ça
relativise un peu les alertes sur les
pénuries parce qu'il y a enfin on entend
régulièrement parler de certaines
pharmacies qui ont certains médicaments
celle d'à côté n'a pas
les hôpitaux c'est un peu la même chose
et donc comment vous voyez
comment on pourrait réguler cette
différence ou cette perte de chance d'un
territoire à l'autre entre les patients
je vais revenir sur les médicaments de
remplacement vous dites on peut
remplacer inhibiteur classique par un
autre inhibiteur calcique dans les faits
c'est pas si simple sur les traitements
chroniques voilà à l'hôpital c'est bien
on peut suivre les effets secondaires on
peut border la prise médicamenteuse
quand le patient repart avec un
médicament qui est pas celui qui l'a
d'origine sur un traitement chronique un
le risque hyatrogène est important et et
et secondo
on a des effets liés à la
pharmacocinétique entre autres qui font
que on n'a pas forcément la même qualité
de traitement sur sur des maladies
chroniques donc comment est-ce que vous
avez alors hors hôpital bien sûr est-ce
qu'il y a une réflexion
d'un package pour accompagner simplement
les patients et les aider hormis ce que
transmet le pharmacien au comptoir mais
qui est parfois
sans oublier en tout cas moi maîtriser
une fois rentré chez soi avec sa boîte
et donc ça fait ça fait partie des
effets secondaires et du coup des
pénuries de de médicaments on a
d'ailleurs demandé à la CNAM de nous
estimer ce coup là et puis revenir sur
sur les appels d'offres
nationaux
avec un conseil de d'Apple d'offre
régionaux j'aurais mis en savoir un peu
plus sur ces appels d'offres nationaux
sur quel type de médicaments il porte
est-ce que c'est fait de façon régulière
ou exceptionnelle vous avez parlé des
dispositifs médicaux mais en matière de
médicaments
je voulais avoir des précisions
là-dessus et pour terminer
comment
comment vous pensez que on pourrait
comment dire créer une solidarité
hôpital
[Musique]
médecine libérale et pharmacie
d'officine pour pouvoir avoir des stocks
communs c'est une question mais la
question se pose à un moment pour que
des stocks communs et qui puissent y
avoir
j'allais dire un transfert de l'hôpital
vers l'officine quand c'est nécessaire
puisque certains médicaments notamment
des anticancéreux de suivi de cancer se
font à domicile et pas à l'hôpital
voilà j'arrêterai là sur le des
conditionnements je pense que c'est un
vrai sujet et que il faut que ça sorte
des problèmes comment dire liés
aux branches professionnelles et qu'on
arrive à trouver une solution Haddock
pour pouvoir l'utiliser quand on en a
besoin
que je peux le constater juste je
suis désolé parce que je vais être
obligé de partir donc
concernant le prix européen bah c'est en
fait c'est simple enfin je pense que
c'est simple il suffit de de fixer des
prix sur des critères objectifs tout
simplement j'ai cité tout à l'heure le
prix de revêt industriel ben c'est voilà
le prix de l'Industrielle il est c'est
quelque chose de très objectif ensuite
pour les pour les médicaments innovants
bien évidemment qu'il faut intégrer la
recherche la recherche et développement
donc je pense que c'est très facile de
quand on connaît la durée de vie par
exemple si on a payé très cher les les
médicaments contre l'hépatite C c'est
parce qu'on savait qu'on a des guérir
définitivement les petites c'est pour ça
que ça a été payé c'est pour ça qu'on a
payé cher parce que la durée de vie du
médicament elle était très courte parce
que et donc fallait fallait que
l'industriel puisse s'y retrouver dans
son truc mais par contre ce qui était
pas c'est pas normal c'est que le le
prix était variable en fonction de la
solvabilité du de les états quoi donc
c'est voilà donc faut voir ça ça c'est
voilà un peu sur les les prix européens
[Musique]
concurrence à l'unité il n'y a pas de
souci puisque toutes les informations
sont sur le
son sur le médicament d'accord donc là à
un moment donné nous ça fait des années
à l'hôpital qu'on demande des conditions
militaires il y a que la moitié des des
médicaments qui sont sur le marché qui
sont en conditionnement unitaire donc
déjà
imposons un peu enfin faut faire un
travail sur ce sujet là parce que et le
problème c'est que et il y a et c'est
vrai que les marchés sont pas forcément
en Europe sont pas forcément les mêmes
il y a des il y a des il y a des des
États qui demandent plutôt d'avoir du
vrac donc je sais donc à un moment donné
il faut il va faut savoir ce qu'on veut
mais moi honnêtement des conditionné
mettre des petits comprimés dans des
sachets et Machin comme ça se fait aux
États-Unis honnêtement je je sais pas
c'est pas entendre voilà
les blisters parce que c'est du
plastique c'est c'est ça en fait c'est
en fait on consommait énormément
d'emballage si on fait unitaire c'est ça
le problème en fait c'est
ensuite comment comment je préviens les
médecins moi je les appelle au téléphone
là on est en rupture faut modifier la
prescription voilà voilà ce que je te
propose et puis voilà c'est comme ça que
ça se passe
voilà on a encore humain
voilà et bon moi personnellement le
déperupteur j'ai pas grand chose à dire
parce qu'à l'hôpital c'est compliqué
avec nos systèmes d'information si on a
du mal à interfacer avec et puis et puis
[Musique]
elle est contingentements vous avez
évoqué ça oui alors déjà il existe déjà
des dispositifs pour les les
médicaments importés
non enfin souvent les médicaments qui
sont apportés pour compenser une pénurie
son qu'on son sont autorisés sur le
territoire français uniquement par le
biais des pharmaciens usage intérieures
parler par l'hôpital donc c'est
contingenté à l'hôpital et ses produits
sont et ces médicaments sont
rétrocédables
donc là ça oblige ça oblige voilà sans
les officines et ça oblige ça oblige les
patients à venir à l'hôpital ça ça se
dispositif qui existe mais le problème
des contingentements en fait on le
connaît tous c'est à dire que le
problème c'est que les contingentements
ils sont ils sont évalués en fonction
des de nos historiques de consommation
c'est-à-dire que le laboratoire dit ben
voilà vous aviez vous consommiez tant
bon on vous donne tant voilà aimer mais
en fait c'est jamais adapté à nos réel
besoin donc donc voilà
les appels d'offres nationaux c'est tous
les c'est tous les médicaments qu'on
peut acheter par appel d'offre c'est
donc c'est le générique c'est rarement
les et c'est rarement les médicaments
innovants tout ce qui est médicament de
monopole ne font pas l'objet d'appel
d'offre en fait ils font l'objet de
marché négocier
voilà et
donc ça contribue
donc ça pèse essentiellement donc sur
les sur les génériqueurs et donc
c'est pareil les génériquesurs donc avec
les appels nationaux on assèche les
Américains et la clause de sauvegarde
elle pèse est essentiellement sur les
génériques ils font pas d'innovation
donc ils peuvent pas compenser voilà
après alors quelques points rapides
premièrement
on s'est réparti de la tâche il va dire
des choses différentes tu vois moi je
veux reprendre sur quatre points le
conditionnement c'est une fausse bonne
idée parce que en fait ça a été un
progrès énorme sur le plan industriel
pour la qualité des produits délivrés
pour la sécurité pour la conservation si
vous avez produit qui sont dans des
sachets c'est n'importe quoi et surtout
pour l'observance pour les patients oui
un patient qui est âgé qui a trois c'est
un minimum 4 x 4 5 médicaments
différents et qui aurait ces cinq
petites sachets qu'il faudrait qu'ils
retrouvent tout à l'heure on parlait des
gélules de telle ou telle couleur c'est
un ingérable et c'est excessivement
dangereux donc c'est une c'est très bien
en théorie mais en pratique ça n'est pas
la dernière chose qu'il faut garder à
l'esprit c'est que le conditionnement il
est il n'est pas libre le
conditionnement il est fixé
le conditionnement il est fixé par la
commission transparence c'est en
fonction de la durée de traitement alors
en effet ces 28 c'est 28 jours ou un
mois en fonction des et donc ce sont
pour des traitements qui sont des
traitements qui se prolongent donc ça
c'est un point qui est très important
parce qu'on en parle très très souvent
dans ce genre de discussion mais en fait
à l'arrivée et vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure les expérimentations ont montré
les limites de cette proposition le
deuxième sujet que je voudrais aborder
c'est les achats en ligne alors les
achats en ligne ils existent
ils sont assez faibles ils sont faibles
en France parce que justement le
médicament il est d'abord remboursé donc
on voit pas pourquoi les gens iraient
acheter sur internet pour payer quelque
chose que par ailleurs ils se font
rembourser donc ils y vont relativement
peu ils vont ils y vont pourquoi pour
acheter des médicaments qui ne veulent
pas ou une osent pas acheter chez leur
pharmacien donc essentiellement les
traitements contre les troupes de
l'érection
les anorexigènes tout ce genre de
produits et à la limite vous voyez les
anabolisants et les gens achètent ce
genre de choses et se les font envoyer
par petit enveloppe kraft qui sont
d'ailleurs très souvent saisis par les
douanes parce que ce sont souvent des
produits qui sont interdits en France le
troisième problème qui se pose pour les
produits en ligne c'est que ce que vous
achetez vous savez pas ce que vous
achetez donc il y a tout le problème des
faux médicaments on en a pas parlé
jusqu'à présent mais c'est un problème
qui est très très important dans
certains pays en France on a la chance
d'avoir un système entre la chaîne et
qui fait que y compris à l'hôpital que
les choses se passent bien il n'y a pas
de de faux médicaments contrairement à
d'autres pays donc le Conseil de l'Ordre
des pharmaciens a mis en place un
système où les pharmacies peuvent en des
médicaments sont listés donc vous pouvez
aller sur le site du Conseil de l'Ordre
et vous voyez les pharmacies qui en
France ont le droit de vendre des
médicaments en ligne et ce sont
seulement des médicaments
d'automédication pas des médicaments la
mort de prescription voilà sur ce sur ce
point troisième point c'est sur le un
point très important dont on parle
relativement peu c'est l'observance tout
à l'heure vous parliez de d'augmentation
de grande consommation les gens achètent
des médicaments ce n'est pas pour ça
qu'il les consomme vous savez que il y a
seulement la moitié des médicaments qui
sont pris ce qui fait que quand une
petite grand-mère décède on trouve dans
sa commode comme moi j'ai vu pour ma
grandante quand elle est décédée une
commode entière avec des tiroirs remplis
de médicaments achetés non consommé donc
ce sur quoi il faut réellement insister
et essayer de travailler y compris dans
le sujet qui nous importe aujourd'hui
c'est l'observance thérapeutique
c'est-à-dire que les gens prennent
réellement les traitements qu'ils sont
qui leur sont prescrits et qui leur sont
délivrés or la substitution vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure la substitution
générique est déjà difficile à gérer
mais la substitution thérapeutique est
encore plus difficile et les gens
sont donc inquiets et quand ils sont
inquiets ils prennent pas leurs
médicaments enfin dernier point juste un
commentaire sur les prix européens il
faut pas se faire d'illusion c'est aussi
une idée un petit peu utopique dans la
mesure où chaque pays à son système de
protection sociale et chaque électeur
dans chaque pays pense qu'il a le même
le meilleur système de protection
sociale et il veut pas en changer donc
on n'aura pas de prix européen à cause
de ça
très bien après ça peut être sur la
liste limitative décider consentie entre
tous les médecins pour entre tous les
pays pour les médicaments critiques
professeur team je terminerai que le
docteur
siriations je réponds sur trois d'entre
elles la première c'était celle des
relations entre les deux académies
pharmacie et médecine et de façon
générale entre les relations entre
médecins pharmaciens elles sont
excellentes permanentes je viens de
signer un rapport sur les praticiens
étrangers qui veulent exercer en France
bon c'est un rapport qui est commun au
médecin aux pharmaciens et au dentiste
et si vous n'étiez pas complètement
convaincu je voudrais que mon voisin qui
représente ici l'Académie de médecine et
l'ancien président de l'Académie de
pharmacie bon je crois qu'on peut pas
avoir de meilleurs de meilleurs preuves
bon donc ce problème est réglé
maintenant
madame madame la rapporteur je crois que
vous avez posé la grande question et la
question qui a la plus difficile
qu'est-ce qui est véritablement
indispensable est-ce que nous pouvons
aujourd'hui avoir une vie
c'est extrêmement difficile je pense que
quand on a fait les émithènes c'était
très habile on a demandé aux industriels
quelles étaient les médicaments qui
commercialisaient et qui est d'un
intérêt thérapeutique majeur
pour la réponse était évidente mais
c'était aussi habile parce que c'était
leur confier le bébé alors confiait le
bébé dans la mesure bon vous considérez
que votre médicament est un médicament
majeur bon ben faites en sorte qu'il
arrive donc méfiez-vous les stocks
a été passé du côté des industriels
maintenant
c'est un problème ce problème des de la
liste de médicaments il y en a plusieurs
il y en a plusieurs le problème c'est
que elle se ressemble pas en particulier
bon nous travaillons à l'heure actuelle
sur ce sujet je n'ose pas vous donner de
conclusion parce que c'est vraiment très
difficile et puis l'Académie n'a pas les
moyens techniques de mettre la liste en
place ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'on travaille avec la DGS c'est qu'on
va travailler avec la NSM sur ce sujet
mais bon
qu'est-ce qui est véritablement
indispensable et on a mis le doigt sur
les problèmes de substitution je crois
que il faut pas se leurrer la
substitution elle est vraiment très très
imparfaite alors en gros je crois qu'on
devrait réussir à avoir 200 250
médicaments en principe actifs bon et
moi il me semble que une des solutions
ça serait d'abord de dire quels sont les
principes actifs indispensables parce
que comme je l'ai mis sur une des
diapositives nous avons des façonniers
nous avons une industrie pharmaceutique
qui est capable finalement techniquement
de faire des médicaments qu'au départ un
exploitent pas
si on a les principes actifs on peut
faire des médicaments en France bon et
d'autre part le collègue hospitalier
c'est dommage qu'il soit parti mais
écoutez on a vu avec l'amoxicilline ils
sont tout à fait capables de faire des
médicaments en cas de pénurie pour
l'amoxicilline ils ont plus de gélules
c'est quand même pas c'est un travail
qu'on sait faire quand on est pharmacien
et donc bah oui bon je crois que c'est
quand même une possibilité donc si vous
voulez pour moi la liste c'est pas
l'analyse des médicaments c'est la liste
des principes actifs et pour certains
médicaments oui c'est une liste les
préparations injectables je crois que
c'est comme ça alors l'autre point aussi
je voulais vous dire c'est que les
médicaments d'innovation ça nous gêne
beaucoup ça nous gêne beaucoup parce que
je vais poser une question très
provocatrice est-ce que l'innovation
correspond à un progrès
oui c'est pour ça que je pense que les
médicaments d'innovation pourraient
peut-être les recevoir sous conditions
si il présente un progrès oui d'accord
si l'on présente pas si vous voulez il y
a deux
il y a deux aspects une innovation ça
peut être fantastique en matière de
recherche ça peut être un papier dans
les t-shirt ça peut même aller au prix
Nobel
est-ce que ça correspond véritablement
est-ce que c'est un concept qui est
génial est-ce que ça correspond à
progrès thérapeutique c'est pas évident
c'est pour ça que je dois dire que quand
je vois maintenant les innovations santé
innovation santé qu'est-ce qu'on met
dedans
voilà les quelques points que je voulais
que je voulais signaler
merci beaucoup professeur docteur Siri
je vais revenir sur les quelques petits
points quand même sur le conditionnement
des boîtes à 28 dans le traitement
chronique et des boîtes à 30 c'est
quelque chose qui devrait pas exister ça
pousse quand même des soucis pratiques
deuxièmement
l'intérêt de savoir ce que c'est comme
médicament nous en pratique nos patients
nous disent avec le nom des CI
connaissent pas ils comprennent pas
l'amoxicilline encore ça commence à
rentrer dans les chaumières comment on
dit mais c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
peut-être qu'on pourra envisager un
pictogramme qui nous dit c'est pour le
cœur c'est pour le poumon je sais pas
envisager un symbole quelque chose qui
nous aide à expliquer aux parents aux
patients pardon que et ben effectivement
ça c'est pas un antibiotique ça c'est
plutôt pour le cœur etc parce que
concrètement on est tout le temps en
train de réexpliquer une ordonnance
quand notamment quand on fait des
substitutions et ça prend du temps mais
on a le temps il faut le faire
la pénurie de l'offre de soins elle
responsable d'une pénurie de médicament
je crois j'ai eu une question comme ça
je crois que c'est une question comme ça
évidemment je pense que surtout ce qui
est prescription si vous avez personne
pour les prescrire il va y avoir
forcément une pénurie de traitement des
gens et quand on voit la quantité de
médicaments non remboursé vendu en
pharmacie et en dehors de tout ce qu'on
prescrit on se dit que quand même les
gens sont prêts à dépenser pour être
soignés et que quand on ne prescrit plus
c'est une vraie perte de chance
sur l'automédication moi je suis désolé
je pense qu'il faudrait que le
conditionnement encore une fois à ce
moment là puisqu'on peut pas le faire au
comprimé j'ai bien entendu toutes les
toutes les réflexions
revenons vers ce que les durées de
traitement des sociétés savantes et puis
que tous les laboratoires qui font de
l'amoxicilline et le même
conditionnement c'est-à-dire 14
comprimés si c'est 14 comprises qu'il
faut pour traiter une angine je dis
n'importe quoi c'est pas ça mais voilà
il faudrait peut-être à ce moment-là
remettre un copier-coller entre ce que
disent les en terme de durée pour telle
pathologie les sociétés savantes pour
que les boîtes soient délivrées à bon
escient parce que moi je suis désolé oui
les gens ne prennent pas leur médicament
7 jours alors donnant six jours mais les
trois comprimés qui vont rester vont
additionner les boîtes et puis après ils
vont les prendre tout seul il y a une
forte part d'automédication de par la
pénurie d'offre de soins et cet
automédication elle est dangereuse
le DGS urgent c'était extraordinaire
mais n'avions aucun problème à gérer le
covid mais on a été saturé donc le mail
maintenant n'en peut plus sauf que quand
même c'était extrêmement bien et moi je
pense que l'alerte elle doit nous venir
je suis désolé c'est pas de la flemme
c'est que on a tellement de
sollicitations qu'il faut qu'elle vienne
et je pense qu'il y a une piste
extrêmement importante puisque vous
savez que maintenant on va voir par les
outils numériques on va envoyer les
ordonnances aux pharmaciens il serait
peut-être intéressant qu'il y a un
retour pour nous dire alerte ce
médicament est en rupture alerte il va
avoir je pense que parler moyen d'outil
numérique on peut obtenir une alerte qui
soit automatique et qui limite nos
contacts non fort agréables avec les
pharmaciens mais qui s'opposent à encore
une fois nos lignes saturées et nos
exercices saturés voilà et je pense que
par le biais des logiciels d'aide à la
prescription on doit pouvoir obtenir
quelque chose c'est une piste vraiment à
développer sur le prix la transparence
est importante on l'a vu avec les
génériques les gens n'ont rien compris
et ils savent pas pourquoi c'est on leur
a imposé des choses et je crois que les
gens ont droit de savoir le prix que ça
coûte et combien la sécurité sociale
d'abord c'est pas gratuit les
médicaments il faut qu'ils sachent
combien ça coûte ça c'est extrêmement
important et quand on fait du tiers pays
en consultation moi j'explique souvent
que c'est pas gratuit parce que la
notion de gratuité quand même favorise
la dépense merci
merci beaucoup pour tous ces éléments
mesdames messieurs je vais lever la
séance et en vous remerciant encore de
la qualité de votre réponse
nous ferons parvenir à un questionnaire
complémentaire et je vous remercie
d'apporter des réponses écrites
circonstanciées que nous que nous allons
vous adresser et
d'ajouter dessus les éléments que vous
jugez utile pour faire avancer nos
travaux en ce qui concerne les pénuries
on voit bien que c'est un sujet très
complexe multifactorielle
mais les tables rondes prescripteurs et
dispensateurs et aussi prescripteur
parce que les pharmaciens ont une
autonomie montre bien que
le sujet du terrain
et pas exactement le sujet de l'hôpital
par exemple et que en ce qui concerne
les pénuries on est dans une dimension
qui amène encore plus de complexité je
vous remercie beaucoup au revoir